hilfe für den libanon nach der explosion
in beirut schicken viele länder dringend
benötigte güter auch deutsche helfer mit
suchhunden sind inzwischen vor ort
testpflicht für reiserückkehrer ab
samstag muss sich jeder der aus einem
risikogebiet kommt auf das corona virus
testen lassen
75 jahre nach hiroshima
der abwurf der ersten atombombe kostet
140000 menschen das leben
heute wird in japan daran erinnert
nachrichten des tages heute mit petra
gerster hüttenabend willkommen bei den
19 uhr nachrichten die vom sport hatten
arbeitnehmern für uns schön guten
eindruck von mir
die verheerende explosion im hafen von
beirut hat nicht nur mehr als 130
menschen leben gekostet und die halbe
stadt verwüstet sondern auch tausende
verletzt
auch eine mitarbeiterin der deutschen
botschaft ist umgekommen
durch die ungeheure druckwelle sind so
viele häuser zerstört worden dass etwa
300.000 menschen obdachlos geworden sind
hilfe aus aller welt rollt nun an das
war der hafen im norden der hauptstadt
beirut vor der explosion
die jetzt seht es hier so aus libanons
tor zur welt liegt in schutt und asche
die zerstörung und das leid in der stadt
sind gewaltig dringend brauchen
hunderttausende menschen jetzt sofort
die internationale hilfe thomas garcia
berichtet zerstörung überall trümmer so
viele sie zeugen vom ausgelöscht im
leben von vernichteten existenzen
inmitten der ruinen heute eine
delegation aus frankreich präsident
makro dort wo vorgestern die detonation
geschah und dort wo in betroffene
umringen voller wut verzweiflung und
hoffnung
es sind die politiker die uns hier töten
ruft die frau niemand hilft uns wir
zählen auf sie nur auf sie und
frankreich mit dem libanon historisch
verbunden hat eine botschaft
ich garantiere ihnen hilfe diese hilfe
wird transparent sein
sie wird hier vor ort sein und nicht
durch bestechungen versickern dann diese
geste trost nähe
angesichts der sorge dass die regierung
nichts tut
deshalb hilft man sich selbst und
gegenseitig aus vielen teilen des
libanon sind sie gekommen um mit
anzupacken
auch international rollt hilfe an
medizinische versorgung notunterkünfte
rettungsteams auch aus deutschland das
technische hilfswerk ist mit 50
einsatzkräften vor ort die mission mit
hunden überleben befinden
auch das deutsche rote kreuz ist
unterwegs um leben zu retten das leben
von verschütteten in einer schwer
verwundeten stadt und eine mitarbeiterin
des deutschen roten kreuzes die seit
jahren im libanon lebt spricht jetzt mit
uns guten abend frau war
sie haben das unglück miterlebt und
packen gleichzeitig vor ort mit an bei
der suche nach verschütteten
wie kommen sie da voran naja wir
unterstützen ganz stark das libanesische
rote kreuz in der suche nach versorgung
der menschen in jeglicher hinsicht
viele menschen sind obdachlos viele
menschen brauchen ganz dringend
medizinische versorgung im moment sind
die krankenhäuser so überlastet dass sie
auch niemanden mehr aufnehmen können
das libanesische rote kreuz hat überall
in der stadt mobile gesundheitsstationen
errichtet wo menschen versorgt werden
können
es ist wirklich immer noch eine absolute
notfallsituation und wirklich
ausnahmezustand in gut ja und dann haben
ja auch noch 300.000 menschen ihre
wohnung verloren
was passiert mit denen es ist ganz
wichtig dass wir so viele notunterkünfte
wie möglich errichten können das ist
momentan das wichtigste und dazu braucht
er nicht nur notunterkünfte sondern auch
utensilien wie seife und und
kochutensilien missbraucht medizinische
versorgung ist braucht ganz viele dinge
die wir momentan beschaffen und mit
unserer schwestern gesellschaft
aufbieten notwendige hilfe vor ort
vielen dank fahrbarer und alles gute für
sie
das gespräch haben wir vor der sendung
aufgezeichnet wenn sie den menschen
helfen wollen können sie gerne spenden
und zwar beim aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe stichwort zdf nothilfe
libanon bahn.de 65 104 106 100 104 106
100 alle infos finden sie auch unter
spenden punkt zdf.de oder im zdf text
auf seite 8 190 und jetzt zu der großen
frage was genau hat die extreme
explosion in beirut ausgelöst
hier im hafen der gattin wohl jahrelang
2750 tonnen ammoniumnitrat
hochgefährlich und offenbar nicht
gesichert eine untersuchungskommission
soll in den nächsten tagen erste
ermittlungsergebnisse liefern und klären
wer verantwortlich ist für die
katastrophe christoph distel hat die
details der tod die zerstörung rund um
den hafen zwei große warum stehen
dahinter
zuerst warum konnte die chemikalie
überhaupt explodieren gilt sie doch als
nur brand fördernd die detonationen
selbst geben die antwort erst ist die
rauchwolke eines feuers zu sehen dann
der erste schlag bei dem wohl
pyrotechnik oder munition hochgeht und
extreme hitze freisetzt diese explosion
die die große weiße wolken dort erzeugt
die es dann sozusagen die voraussetzung
dafür dass das was neben angelagert hat
das ammonium nitrat dann zur umsetzung
gekommen ist
das ist die schwarze wolke und
gleichzeitig auch die immense druckwelle
die alles zerstörte dann das zweite
warum warum lagert das nitrat
tonnenweise im hafen fast sieben jahre
lang mit der rose kam es 2013 von georgi
nach beirut das gilt als sicher der rest
spekulation vielleicht sind schiff und
ladung nach der pleite des eigners im
hafen hängen geblieben oder dieses
gerücht stimmt die islamistische
hisbollah habe die chemikalie
absichtlich nach beirut gelotst für
anschläge irgendwann fakt ist hizbullah
und ammoniumnitrat das passt sagen
experten verhängnisvolle in diesem fall
mit jedem monat länger im hafen wurde
das material gefährlicher die lange
lagerung kann nicht gut sein für eine
chemikalie weil die temperaturen die
beauftragung die klimatischen
bedingungen so ungünstig sind
das sich über einen langen zeitraum
dieser chemikalie die an sich sehr
stabil ist auch langsam zersetzt damit
entstehen produkte die sehr viel
sensibler sind entzündung schon oft hat
der falsche umgang mit ammonium nitrat
zu katastrophen geführt 1921 etwa in
ludwigshafen ein knall noch in münchen
zu hören
559 tote oder 1947 in texas ein frachter
explodiert 600 tote die verantwortlichen
im hafen beirut hätten es also besser
wissen können vielleicht müssen nach
deutschland und damit zur corona krise
und zunächst zu den zahlen die deutlich
nach oben gehen
das robert koch institut meldet mehr als
1000 neue fälle innerhalb von 24 stunden
im schnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich laut johns hopkins
universität täglich 800 menschen neu mit
dem virus angesteckt am vortag lag die
zahl noch bei 730 angesichts dieser
zahlen hat gesundheitsminister sparen an
alle appelliert die hygieneregeln
einzuhalten
das virus nehme keine rücksicht auf die
urlaubszeit wo es eine chance habe
breite es sich aus ab samstag gilt für
rückkehrer aus risikogebieten wie zum
beispiel ägypten oder der spanischen
region katalonien die pflicht sich
testen zu lassen frank buchwald
flughafen frankfurt kohona teststation
urlauber die aus risikogebieten
zurückkommen können sich hier testen
lassen kostenlos und bisher auch
freiwillig ich finde es gut
also ich bin froh dass ich das hier
machen kann und nicht zum hausarzt gehen
es gab eine oma daheim und besonders bei
ihr ist es wichtig dass ich kein corona
mit nach hause bringe samstag jedoch
tritt eine testpflicht in kraft damit
will der gesundheitsminister eine neue
ansteckungsfälle ausbremsen das heißt
wer aus einem solchen risikogebiet kommt
nach deutschland einreist muss ein
testergebnis mitbringen oder hier in
deutschland einen abstrich machen lassen
ein test durchführen lassen
die zahl der korona fälle in deutschland
steigt wieder die meisten sind bisher
jedoch keine reiserückkehrer sondern
gehen auf lokale infektionsherde zurück
etwa fleischfabriken gemüse höfe oder
feiern ohne abstand virologen sprechen
von clustern ist sicherlich wichtig zu
versuchen die klasse gut zu definieren
aber auch natürlich jeden einzelnen
infektionsfall zurückzuverfolgen also
infektionsketten aufzudecken
auch deshalb setzt der minister auf
strikte kontrollen
mir ist sehr bewusst dass das ein
eingriff in die freiheit des einzelnen
ist aber ich finde es ist ein zumutbarer
eingriff die neuen verpflichtenden tests
sind kostenlos sie gelten nicht nur
flughäfen sondern auch für bahnreisende
und wie hier an der autobahn in der nähe
von passau für menschen die mit dem auto
nach deutschland einreisen corona krise
kommt die zweite welle dazu gibt es ein
zdf spezial gleich nach dieser sendung
um 19 uhr 20
außerdem finden sie weitere
informationen über die pandemie auch
online in unserer app und auf zdf heute
ende der ferienzeit für millionen kinder
und jugendliche heißt dass es geht
zurück in die schule und immer mehr
bundesländer schreiben zum start die
maske vor
zumindest an den weiterführenden schulen
so müssen schülerinnen und schüler in
nordrhein westfalen dann auch im
unterricht mundschutz tragen
in berlin brandenburg und mecklenburg
vorpommern kommt beziehungsweise gilt
die masken pflicht dagegen nur in den
gemeinschafts bereichen der schulgebäude
und teilweise auch auf dem schulhof
so sieht es auch in hamburg aus wo heute
der unterricht wieder begann henry maske
auf das schuljahr startet an einer der
größten hamburger schulen gedacht für
1600 schüler und 300 lehrer in dem
moment so die regelung in hamburg wenn
man das schulgelände betritt sie haben
alle die masken dabei und wenn man seine
vergessen hat kann man eine von uns
bekommen die stadt hamburg hat uns
welche zur verfügung gestellt wie haben
aber auch selber welche mit unseren
problemen drucken lassen so dass es auch
so ein bisschen identifikation ist für
die schüler erst am platz dürfen die
schüler die maske abnehmen das erfordert
disziplin und verständnis denn nicht
zuletzt entscheidet auch der richtige
umgang mit dem mund nasenschutz darüber
wie es an hamburgs schulen weiter geht
es ist nicht einfach die masken korrekt
zu verwenden dass wir ja auch jetzt im
alltag wo eben die erwachsenen diese
maske verwenden sollen bei kindern ist
das noch mal ein ganz anderes problem
insofern ist es wichtig dass die kinder
darauf auch vorbereitet werden auf eine
richtige verwendung um mögliche
infektionen schnell zu begrenzen dürfen
sich nur schüler eines jahrgangs näher
kommen zu einem anderen gilt abstands
pflicht ob alles gut wird entscheidet
hamburg spätestens in 14 tagen am montag
und dienstag kommen die neuen fünft und
erstklässler dazu in der hansestadt sind
es übrigens in diesem jahr so viele wie
noch nie zuvor
in der deutschen industrie hat corona
tiefe spuren hinterlassen
doch es geht wieder aufwärts sagen
zahlen des statistischen bundesamts die
auftragseingänge stiegen im juni um 27,9
prozent gegenüber mai im vergleich zum
vorjahresmonat waren es allerdings 11,3
prozent weniger auch deshalb zweifelt
der bundesverband der deutschen
industrie ihren eine schnellen
kompletten erholung vor allem die
aufträge aus dem ausland hinken noch
hinterher
wenig optimistisch schaut die lufthansa
in die zukunft der flugverkehr nach wie
vor eingebrochen
im zweiten quartal stand unter dem
strich ein weiterer dicker verlust minus
1,5 milliarden
konzernchef spur schließt inzwischen
sogar betriebsbedingte kündigungen nicht
mehr aus isabel de la vega berichtet wir
treffen eine stewardess der lufthansa
sie möchte nicht erkannt werden viele
junge flugbegleiter erzählt sie zittern
jetzt um ihren arbeitsplatz
ich fliege noch nicht so lange für die
lufthansa damit werde ich vermutlich zu
den ersten gehören die entlassen werden
ich habe zwei kinder wenn ich den job
verlieren wird es mit den kindern
richtig schwierig einen neuen zu finden
das quartalsergebnis der lufthansa ist
das schlechteste ihrer geschichte im
vergleich zum vorjahreszeitraum ist die
zahl der passagiere um 96 prozent
eingebrochen
flankiert wurden diese zahlen von einem
offenen brief des lufthansa chefs an
seine mitarbeiter zitat betriebsbedingte
kündigungen können wir überall dort wo
modelle und vereinbarungen zur
kompensation von überkapazitäten fehlen
nicht mehr ausschließen
überkapazitäten gemeint ist zu viel
personal das zum beispiel durch krisen
tarifverträge zugeständnisse machen soll
weil die gespräche zu diesen modellen
ins stocken geraten sind ist jetzt zum
ersten mal von kündigungen die rede
ein unlauteres druckmittel kritisieren
die gewerkschaften werden neun
milliarden euro staatshilfe kriegt muss
auch die beschäftigten dahinter schützen
und da sind betriebsbedingte kündigungen
oder auch nur die ankündigung des ganzen
der absolut falsche weg der konflikt um
die jobs wird sich zuspitzen
22.000 vollzeitstellen
die lufthansa abbauen offen ist ob das
reichen wird
und jetzt zu einem ereignis das die welt
für immer verändert hat
vor 75 vor 75 jahren am 6 august 1945 um
8 uhr 15 warf der us bomber enola gay
eine atombombe über der japanischen
stadt hiroshima ab zum ersten mal wurde
diese zerstörerische waffe in einem
krieg eingesetzt innerhalb von minuten
löscht die druckwelle und ein feuersturm
die stadt fast vollständig aus
zehntausende menschen starben sofort bis
ende 1945 waren es 140 1000 tote infolge
von verbrennungen oder verstrahlung
stefanie schöne bauen über das gedenken
in japan
er war sieben jahre alt an diesem tag
vor 75 jahren er erlebte das entfernen
und überlebte als die usa die atombombe
über hiroshima abwerfen hiroshima wird
zum symbol von zerstörung tod und für
den wahnsinn des krieges war groß es gab
dieses große feuer dann verteilte sich
überall staub und dieser hochradioaktive
schwarze regen prasselte nieder
innerhalb weniger stunden und tage
sichern tausende menschen dahin
wie viele insgesamt an den folgen des
schwarzen regens und der
strahlenkrankheit sterben ist bis heute
nicht bekannt
drei tage später wird eine weitere
atombombe über nagasaki abgeworfen
70.000 menschen sterben
kurz danach kapitulierte japan ich bin
hier weil ich kämpfen werde solange ich
lebe
denn ich will noch mit meinen eigenen
augen sehen dass es eine welt ohne
atomwaffen gibt kazuyoshi ist heute 82
jahre alt er will dass seine stimme noch
gehört wird die erinnerung wach bleibt
um 8 uhr 15 vor 75 jahren kam die hölle
mit der bombe nach hiroshima
eine schweigeminute damit die welt nicht
vergisst und das wissen dass es weltweit
noch rund 13.400 atomare sprengköpfe
gibt in deutschland rollt gerade die
nächste hitzewelle an
da steigt bei vielen die lust sich in
flüssen und seen abzukühlen
doch die deutsche lebens rettungs
gesellschaft warnt schwimmen an
ungesicherten badestellen bleibt
gefährlich
laut dlrg starben in den ersten sieben
monaten des jahres 192 menschen beim
baden
das sind 63 weniger als im
vorjahreszeitraum
vor allem weil der sommerbeginn nicht
zur wand war ja zum sport und nun zu dir
norbert drei deutsche vereine im
achtelfinale der europa league aber
jetzt ist eine ausgliederung gestern
abend der vfl wolfsburg nach der 0 3
klatsche gegen bonn jetzt noch immer
einen leverkusen und frankfurt die
eintracht spielt gleich gegen basel
trotz der 0 zu 3 hinspielniederlage gibt
frankfurt die hoffnung nicht auf nach
dem motto das wunder von bern das gab es
ja auch warum ich jetzt ein wunder von
basel im baseler st -jakob-park genannt
joggeli will adi hütter dass europa
league wunder vollbringen acht trainings
tage müssen reichen um beim defensiv
stärksten schweizer team mindestens drei
besser noch mehr tore zu schießen und
wir müssen natürlich versuchen das spiel
anzunehmen ich kann mir vorstellen dass
fc basel versuchen wir dieses 13 0 zu
verteidigen müssen sozialem versuchen
kontrolliert nach vorne zu spielen
trotzdem dagegen unter druck zu setzen
und die situationen die wir zu 100
prozent da vorfinden werden müssen wir
auch nutzen
dabei setzt weiter auf das sturm duo
andre silber und bastos eine
kontrollierte offensive soll dafür
sorgen dass sich die fehler aus der 0 zu
3 hinspielpleite nicht wiederholen
dennoch ist eines klar um in europa
league viertelfinale einzuziehen braucht
frankfurt heute das wunder von basel
der gesundheitszustand des gestern abend
bei der polen-rundfahrt verunglückten
niederländischen rad profi fabio
jacobsen ist laut seiner behandelnden
ärzte ernst aber stabil
jacobsen vorne rechts war von seinem
landsmann dylan grüne wegen putz vor der
familie abgedrängt worden und raste mit
tempo 80 und sagen der 23 jährige wurde
ins krankenhaus geflogen und fünf
stunden notoperiert
am sonntag wären sie zu ende gegangen
die olympischen sommerspiele in tokio
die ja corona bedingt auf nächstes jahr
verschoben wurden und verschoben wurde
heute auch die riesigen olympischen
ringe in der bucht von tokio
der grund die 69 tonnen schwere
stahlkonstruktion die soll dem namen
yokohama aufpoliert werden damit sie
spätestens zu den spiele in einem jahr
in frischem glanz erstrahlt der hoffen
wir dass die spiele auch in einem jahr
dort stadt sind das wäre schön wenn
überhaupt alles wieder so wäre früher
die heißen tage mit viel sonne sind da
und steigern sich noch bis zum
wochenende
mehr dazu gleich im wetter von ist
intern so viel von uns danke für ihr
interesse
das heute journal um 21.45 mit marietta
slomka hier beginnt jetzt das spezial
zur corona krise wir sehen uns dann
hoffentlich morgen wieder um 19 uhr
ihnen noch einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter in den nächsten
tagen wird es noch heißer und das liegt
an diesem umfangreichen hoch was sich
hier immer weiter stabilisiert hier
kommt auch noch aus dem südwesten
europas heiße luft auf der vorderseite
dieses tiefs diese kombination sorgt
dafür dass die hitzewelle sich weiter
fortsetzt schauen wenn die nacht da wird
es ordentlich abkühlen mit temperaturen
zwischen 17 und 10 grad eine gelegenheit
noch einmal die wohnung gut
durchzulüften denn in den nächsten tagen
werden die nächte insbesondere auch
ziemlich mild bleiben morgen im
tagesverlauf gibt es dann sehr viel
sonnenschein in der westhälfte und auch
im süden sonst sind einige harmlose
wolken unterwegs es fällt keinen regen
und das bei temperaturen von 31 bis 32
grad im osten deutschlands 30 sind im
südosten bis zu 36 am niederrhein an den
alpen und an der ostsee sind es 27 grad
also ein ziemlich heißer tag
es geht aber noch heißer und zwar die
kommenden tage samstag bis 38 grad fast
überall sonnenschein ab sonntag gibt es
hier und dort einige wolken aber es
bleibt weiterhin größtenteils trocken
ein schöner abend